Namo tassa bhagavato harhato samma sambuddhassa Namo tassa bhagavato harhato samma sambuddhassa
Namo tassa bhagavato arahat sammasambuddhassa homage to the Buddha, the blessed, noble and fully self-enlightened one.
So we're still really investigating these khanda, the five aggregates into which the Buddha dissected our experience.
So it's the body with its sensations.
Sanya, which were the perceptual faculties which grow into concepts, our intellect.
Today I want to talk about Vedana, which is feeling.
The fourth was Sankara, which just loosely we can sometimes translate as volitional conditioning.
So it's where the will comes in.
And then finally our act of cognition or consciousness.
So just looking at Vedana, so there are
five types and it's a slightly different way of looking at things two of them are physical that's pretty straightforward for us we have pleasant and unpleasant sensations that's pretty easy for us to distinguish but there's also distinguished as pleasant and unpleasant mental sensations and that's where the confusion comes in because normally speaking we talk about feelings and emotions
and I think they shade into each other Emotions are very complex things but when you just go into the body they manifest as some sort of feeling
depression is heavy, anger is hot and all that and that's what we're looking at when we are just feeling a sensation in the body which we recognize is caused by a mental state rather than the body itself and it's distinguishing those two and the fifth one is of course the neutral states of both the body sensations and the mental sensations
And the reason we distinguish those two is because the Buddha taught that the physical part of our nature and the mental part were two actually distinct forms of energy.
They both suffered from impermanence, they don't constitute a self or a soul or a person, but they are two different energy systems, the one affecting the other.
And you're sitting when you get a sore knee, the mind becomes agitated.
If you feel depressed, then the mind becomes heavy.
Or if you feel tired, the body becomes heavy.
So that distinguishing, that deconstructing of our experience is part and parcel of understanding
that this psycho-physical organism that we experience ourselves to be does not actually constitute an entity as such, something which is whole, entire, self-subsistent, can exist outside this universe, all that sort of stuff.
It just isn't that.
And you can also, he also splits it up again, dissects it again into the various feelings that arise from the six, well, seven senses.
So sight, what we see is also a sensation, it also comes under the physical feelings.
Hearing, what we hear comes under physical feelings, bodily feelings.
So by dividing that, then of course we can see that there are something like 30 different types of sensations and feelings.
These are only types, as you know, within each type there are myriad types of feelings and sensations.
And I dare say, it's never the case that one is exactly the same as the other, like leaves on the tree, they're not the same.
The other thing to say about Vedana is that they're always in any level of consciousness.
So whenever you're conscious, there has to be the factor of Vedana.
So if you're seeing, there's the feeling or sensation of light.
If you're hearing, there's the sensation of sound and so on.
So it's not possible for there to be a conscious moment without there being some sort of feeling.
Now the importance of
The way he separates this out, feeling, comes up in the discourse on how to establish this right mindfulness, which is about seeking liberation, a Satipaṭṭhāna discourse.
And there's a second section there, after physical feelings, bodily feelings,
there comes vedana-vedanupāsati which means to see feelings in feelings it's a sort of funny construction it's what's known as a locative case where you're in something so it's to feel, to see, to experience feelings in feelings now that seems like a double take
But all he's saying is to try and separate out feelings completely from perceptual things, from emotional fantasies and stuff, and to just center completely on feeling.
What is a feeling?
To ask yourself the question, what is a feeling?
What is a sensation?
because normally speaking we don't experience life in this way we just experience it in the fullness of our personality and physical contact with the world but by doing so it's all part and parcel of seeing how this life works for us and the
This confusion between emotion and feeling, when I say confusion, it's the English and it's the way that we experience things, is something that we deal with when we come to the Sankara, which is the next section to do with the will.
So then it becomes quite complicated because everything then begins to motor up into what we would consider an experience.
So that, short and sweet, is the description of Vedana.
I hope my words have been of some assistance.
May you be fully liberated from all your painful Vedana, sooner rather than later.